TOM: So my name is
Tom [INAUDIBLE].
I've been working here
at Google for a while
and working with mindfulness and
meditation programs for a while
as well.
We've had the really
great opportunity
to host many wonderful
teachers of meditation,
and mindfulness, and Buddhist
practice over the years
at Google.
And it's a great honor to
be able to extend tradition.
And so with that
in mind, I'd like
to introduce Khenpo
Karten Rinpoche, who
is visiting us here from his
center down in Pacific Grove.
He's got a wonderful
center very nearby.
Khenpo Karten Rinpoche
has an illustrious career,
having spent many of his years
in personal retreat, some
of that retreat given
to him as an assignment
by His Holiness the Dalai Lama.
And he is also traveling around
the world very extensively.
So he has a nice community here
in sort of the South Bay Area
or whatever you want to call it.
But he also has
communities Southeast Asia
and other places
around the world.
Just after this talk, he'll
be flying, for example,
to the East Coast.
And so if anybody listening
in Boston or New York,
I believe Rinpoche has some
dates for upcoming teachings
in those places as well.
I'd also to introduce David
Molk, who's our translator.
David is also a really
wonderful and kind translator
of Tibetan work.
We're glad to have them
both here in our presence.
Rinpoche will be
presenting a talk
on compassion and cooperation.
And so with that, I will
shut up and hand it over
to the people who actually know
what they're talking about.
Thanks everybody for coming.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
Good morning everyone.
I thank you so much today
I am here with you all.
Because this is Google.
I always use the Google.
I use a lot of Google always.
Sometimes when I [INAUDIBLE],
they give me the big questions.
They say, I don't answer.
[INAUDIBLE] check the Google.
[LAUGHTER]
But my English is not very good.
I have a very good translator.
Today I'm just here with you
about love and compassion.
And first you have to
know, I am from Tibet.
I am monk.
I know only the dharma.
That's where today I talk
of the love and compassion
and how do we work together,
which is very, very important.
I'm really happy to talk today.
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So this is
pretty much my first time
to have the opportunity
to speak at Google,
which is the worldwide famous,
known all over the world.
I'm very happy to be here
and to meet you all today.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: And in
particular, this subject
of love and compassion
I find to be
something that's very important
for all of us and for you all.
So I'm very happy especially
to talk on that subject.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So in my own
practice of any kind of dharma
activity that I'm
going to undertake,
I find it very important
to set a good motivation
and intention.
And so I'm going to do that
now as I begin this talk.
And I'd like to ask all
of you and all those who
will see this over the
internet to take a moment
to set a good, altruistic,
positive, pure motivation.
Because that is what will
really make this worthwhile,
and productive, and fruitful.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So I want to
speak about how we develop,
how we work together
with love and compassion.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So I thought
to organize my talk
in three categories, first, the
disadvantages and the drawbacks
of lack of compassion, the
problems that arise when there
is a lack of love and compassion
between people, secondly,
the great advantages
and benefits of love
and compassion, and thirdly,
how love and compassion
can develop.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: First
of all, the benefits
of love and compassion,
they're so important.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So myself,
being a Buddhist,
to say a word about it
in a Buddhist context,
in all the ways of
Buddhism, all the vehicles,
whether it's the
Theravadan or bodhisattvan
vehicle or the Tantric
practice, love and compassion
is really the basis
of the foundation
of all of Buddhist teachings.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So
something that is so
important in the context
of Buddhist teachings
is also extremely important
for the world at large.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So a lot of
people may have the impression
that compassion is something
you feel for others.
It's other-focused.
It's something that's
for their benefit,
not understanding that it's very
beneficial for the person who
develops that
compassion themselves.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So
it's not like that.
It's not just for
the sake of another.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: Because when
someone genuinely develops
love and compassion
in a very sincere way,
that actually brings great
happiness to that person
himself.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So the
problem is, when
there's a lack of
love and compassion,
is that a person becomes
too self-centered, too
self-focused.
They're unable to look outwards.
It's as if this closes the
door on their awareness
to outer world and
other living beings.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So it's good
open, to widen our horizons,
to think in a more vast way.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So when we
undergo great difficulties,
painful situations, and so
on, then from the Buddhist
view-- in the
context of Buddhism,
we see that as something
that we've created ourselves
in terms of karma.
We've planted the
seeds for that.
But if we just remain focused on
our problem and our suffering,
we get angry about it,
get self-pitying about it,
then OK, we've got one problem.
But our mental attitude
is piling another problem
on top of that.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So we may
experience the same kinds
of sufferings and difficulties.
But to me, the big difference
is in the way that we handle
and the way that we
deal with it, especially
if we a more vast, open
minded kind of perspective.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So when someone
is practicing Buddhism,
there are different levels
at which it can be practiced.
And at the level of
the highest capacity,
the person remains
very much focused
on attainment of enlightenment
in a very short time
or a short number of lifetimes.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: Now the
power of their mind
is really able to provide
happiness for them continually,
both in this lifetime and into
the future lifetimes as well.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So this
is the first level
in which that power of
the practice or the mind
enables a person to
maintain happiness
in this and all lifetimes.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So at
that highest level,
those problems never create
a problem or unhappiness
for the practitioner.
But at a minimum
level, then there's
these special way
in which the person
is able to deal with problems is
that they have a lot of tools,
a lot of methods from the
teachings, which enables them
to transform what would be
difficult circumstances,
bad conditions of various
types, into something that's
beneficial for their
spiritual path,
to transform negative conditions
into positive conditions
for their spiritual path.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: He said, the dharma
provides them with the tools
to do that.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
Just like in food, OK,
food-- when you get
hungry, you have to eat.
Dharma is just like food.
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: And
at the very least,
the dharma should
provide a person
with means of dealing with
difficulties and problems
to at least the point
where they don't become
so overwhelming to
the person that they
feel like they've
got to end their life
or something like that.
It gives them means by which
to prevent such an outcome, so
to be able to deal with it.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: And so people
in such situations,
they don't know where to look
for protection or refuge.
They seek it in outside
things like alcohol or drugs.
And so this kind
of outcome is what
at least should be the benefit
of having the basis of a dharma
practice, teachings of Buddha.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE: I'm
not talking [INAUDIBLE].
I'm not talking about
the dharma here.
I just talking about here love
and compassion, compassion.
I don't know what the
translate to English.
I don't know what this
compassion mean, OK?
In Tibetan, we call
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
When I use these words,
they make me cry.
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So the
word in Tibetan
compassion, [SPEAKING TIBETAN],
and [SPEAKING TIBETAN],
great compassion, when I
think about great compassion,
this really is very emotional.
It brings a lot of-- it
brings tears in my eyes.
But we can think
about compassion
in its relative sense,
when on the relative level,
the feeling of empathy and wish
to free others from suffering.
But when we say
great compassion,
then that brings
to my mind a sense
of ultimate, ultimate
great compassion, which
is connected with
understanding of selflessness,
ultimate truth, and entities of
Buddha and [SPEAKING TIBETAN].
So then great compassion
I think of as conjoined
with that understanding
of ultimate truth.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: But now I
want to bring my remarks
more specifically to love
and compassion, which
is not something that's
exclusive to the teachings
of Buddha.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: Whatever
you want in the world
needs these qualities
of love and compassion.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So in, again,
the contest of Buddhism
and the importance of
love and compassion,
there's a quotation from the
great Indian master Shantideva,
where he talks about how all
the happiness that arises
in the world--
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: --that arises from
the wish for others' happiness,
love, wishing others happiness.
And I want to draw from that
quotation in what I say here.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So that
quotation in full
says that all the happiness
that exists in the world
arises from wishing others
happiness, from the love,
wishing others happiness.
And all the suffering
that exists in the world
arises from the
self-centered, seeking
only one's own happiness.
So there's not a
need to say much.
Just look at the Buddhas
who are dedicated
to the welfare of
others as opposed
to ordinary limited beings
who act in an immature way
and seek only
their own happiness
and wander in suffering.
Just look at the difference.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So to take
the example from Buddhism,
bodhisattvas such
as His Holiness
the Dalai Lama
living in this world
today, the fact that he can
remain in a happy state of mind
and provide so much
and happiness to others
is a result of
this being focused
on the welfare of others, having
given up self-centeredness
and selfishness.
Because of this
altruistic mind, he
remains in a state of happiness
and able to bring so much
happiness to others.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: But as
for the opposite
of that, which we see
so much this world today
in our own experience
and in other worse
realms of existence,
all those sufferings
that arise come from this
self-centered attitude,
the selfish attitude, which
then causes people to look down
on others and disparage
others, and then on that basis
create negative karma.
And it causes so much suffering.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: And in the
world in general and here,
no matter what
situation you look at,
happiness can't really be
sustained by ones self alone.
We're all interconnected.
And the only way that the
welfare of any one person
can arise is in
dependence upon others.
So especially in
this world today
in which we're so
interconnected,
all of their happiness
depends on others.
It's as if we've
become big family.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So to take
the example of a merchant
or someone who's
selling things or even
to take the example
of Google, in order--
it's not possible
for just a few people
to create this
completely on their own.
There needs to be people
who want that service, who
want those goods.
And in the case of
Google, there are
millions of people who
use and look at it.
And that then brings benefit
to the works and people
involved with Google as well.
So there's a great benefit
for ones self and others.
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
DAVID MOLK: And
to think about it
in a vaster sense of the world
that all of our happiness
depends upon others.
So yes, there is effort that
we need to put forth ourselves,
maybe a good percentage of it.
But if it was just
all left to ourselves,
we wouldn't be
able to manage it.
The success depends upon others.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So how can these
qualities be developed?
How can we go about developing
love and compassion?
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So there
are two ways in Buddhism
for this development.
And I'm going to focus
on one of them, which
uses the example of
oneself to understand
others and understand
that just as oneself
doesn't want to experience
suffering, so it is for others.
Just as oneself would like
to experience happiness,
understand it's just
the same for others.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So in our own case,
we're completely sure, 100%,
that we don't want
problems, suffering.
We want happiness
and fulfillment.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So the fact is
that every living creature
has exactly that same attitude.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So the first
step is to open our mind
to this kind of understanding
that that is true,
that just as I want happiness
and don't want suffering,
that is completely true for
another and for all others.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So that in itself
can prevent a lot of problems.
When we get an urge to
strike out at someone else
or to hurt another,
there's no other means
necessary like meditation
or recitation of a mantra,
but just simply to
bring that thought
to mind that, oh, this person
doesn't want suffering.
This person wants happiness
just as much as I do.
And that very awareness, it can
bring a stop to that impulse
to strike out and harm another.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So then by
contemplating that continually
and thinking both
about the benefits that
derive from warm, harmonious,
compassionate mind attitude
towards others as
well as the drawbacks
and the great problems
that arise from maintaining
a selfish,
self-centered attitude,
continually contemplating the
pros and cons of that, then
along with that, then
bring it into whereas
how it relates to
others, and realizing
that they don't want suffering.
And they have these same kinds
of problems and dynamics.
And so to bring that into the
way that one relates to others,
you'll be more kind to.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So the work
that we do is not easy.
And also this development
of love and compassion
is not something
that's very easy to do.
So it takes continual
perseverance and patience.
There needs to be a lot
of patience, forbearance
for developing these attitudes
and working with others.
So patience really
need to be there as
like a foundation or a great
aid to the development of love
and compassion.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So it's
like the container that
needs to be there to hold,
or the enclosure there
that needs to be there in
order to support that love
and compassion.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So in the context
of the vows of a bodhisattva,
there's a very
strong determination
that I'm not going to do
anything to harm others.
And if at all possible,
I'm going to help them.
I'm going to benefit them.
So there needs to be this kind
of determination and patience
that's behind maintaining,
developing this attitude.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So
patience, forbearance
is something
extremely important.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So
patience can apply
in a lot of different areas,
patience towards an enemy,
patience towards dharma and
spiritual development, patience
in the work that
you're doing to serve
others, which is not easy.
It takes a lot of patience
to do that hard work
for the benefit of others.
So that's a very
valid form of patience
and valuable form of patience.
There can be patience for
people that annoy you,
that make you angry, and so on.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So it's said
in the teachings of Buddha
that patience is the
greatest of austerities.
It's one of the most
difficult practices,
one of the most difficult
practices to maintain.
So it's a great austerity to
be able to practice patience.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: He said, without
anybody to annoy you,
then who are you going
to be patient with?
[LAUGHTER]
You know, if everyone's just
fine and having a great time,
then how am I going to persevere
in developing this love
and compassion?
What kind of challenges
is that going to present?
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So
love and compassion
is something that
needs to be developed
in place of hatred and anger.
So it needs to displace those.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: And so
in that case, then
we need to be able to develop
love and compassion for someone
who is an adversary, someone
who provokes that anger
and hatred in us.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: Then so--
[SPEAKING TIBETAN].
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN] He forget.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID MOLK: Simple to learn.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE: He needs
to hear, as he [INAUDIBLE].
Anyway--
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID MOLK: [SPEAKING TIBETAN]
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So to support
that development of love
and compassion, there definitely
needs to be this patience
and perseverance to develop it-
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: --from
starting right
in with those around
you, your family
and your close associates.
So not getting angry with
enemies-- and that also
needs to start right at home to
keep that patience and loving
attitude right towards the
relations in one own family.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: Think--
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE: Think--
DAVID MOLK: Globally--
KHENPO KARTEN
RINPOCHE: --globally.
DAVID MOLK: Act--
KHENPO KARTEN
RINPOCHE: Act locally.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID MOLK: So he really
likes this phrase,
think globally, act locally.
We want to keep our
intentions very, very vast.
That's what we're intending.
But where to start with it
is right in our own vicinity
and our own family as well.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So we need to
develop this within ourselves
first.
And then from there, it can
spread out through the world.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So this needs to
be practiced in the family
to begin with.
And if there is love and caring
between parents and members
of a family, then it can
spread to the neighbors.
It can spread to the vicinity.
It can spread to the country.
And this is really
they only way.
Because lacking inner
peace ourselves,
if we want to try to provide
inner peace for the world,
there's no way that's
going to happen.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: Now
when we trace back
the root cause of all
the different conflicts
and sufferings that
exist in the world,
they really do trace
back to this lack
of caring between people, lack
of love, lack of compassion.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So there needs
to be this kind of attitude
to alleviate problems in the
world, in our own country,
and around the world--
this understanding
that others have exactly
the same wish for happiness
and wish to avoid suffering and
be free of problems as I do,
and I'm going to do my
very best to help them.
And even if I can't,
then at least,
I'm not going to harm them.
And keep this kind of
determination and commitment.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: And so if peace
is going to come in the world,
it will need to
come in this way.
It can't come from outside.
It has to be developed
within ourselves.
And when it is developed
within ourselves,
then there's the
real possibility
that it can spread to the world.
And if we do this, some
time in the future,
there will actually
be peace on earth.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So in the practice
of the teachings of Buddha,
we develop a
feeling of closeness
and warmth towards others just
as if they were our closest
relations such as our mother.
And even in recitations,
we'll refer to all living
beings as our mother.
In other words, in Tibetan,
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]--
all sentient beings are my
mother, who have been mother.
And so even if we don't
contemplate that deeply,
to just say the
words, to me, they're
very powerful words to bring
in that sense of that closest
relationship with other living
beings, no matter who they are.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So it's so
obvious, all the problems
that come about, that
develop in the world
because of lack of
caring, lack of compassion
and love for others.
But if we do practice this
development of love and caring
for others, then as
I mentioned before,
as for how much direct
benefit it brings to others,
that may be something
to be investigated.
But as far as the
way it makes you
feel when you have a great
feeling of love and compassion
for others, you will
feel very happy.
You will bring great happiness
and peace to yourself.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: We need to recognize
this essential importance
of love and compassion,
that when it's there,
it provides happiness for
the person who has it it.
It makes them much more
able to benefit others.
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
DAVID MOLK: It
leads to happiness
in the short term, in the
long run, in this lifetime,
and all lifetimes.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN] Time?
TOM: 10 minutes.
KHENPO KARTEN
RINPOCHE: 10 minutes?
Oh.
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So developing
love and compassion
can very much enhance our
work and the effectiveness
of the work that you do here.
And it really needs to
be supported by patience.
When someone annoys you or
with someone you don't like,
you need to be able to practice
that patience and forbearance
in order to continually develop
the love and compassion.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So as for
these words in English,
love and compassion,
I don't know
how much power they convey.
But in Tibetan, when we speak
of love, [SPEAKING TIBETAN],
and compassion,
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]--
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: Much
better names, he says.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
Is Tibetan names for love.
I don't know how much--
[LAUGHTER]
DAVID MOLK: But in
the context of the--
[LAUGHTER]
In the context of
the teachings, these
are so fundamental,
so important.
They bring so much to my
mind to think about them.
In the context of one
type of meditation called
the sevenfold cause
and effect meditation,
we begin with recognizing
other living thins no matter
who they are as one's closest
relation such as one's mother--
and then thinking
about the kindness
that we receive from the mother,
wishing to repay that kindness,
developing loving kindness
and compassion passion,
and then a sense of
universal responsibility
followed by a wish to attain
enlightenment in order
to be able to liberate
all living beings,
and then finally that
conjoining of an understanding
of ultimate truth, selflessness.
All of this is
fundamentally centered
around development of
love and compassion.
It really derives from that.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So it's really
the most admired quality
and realization in the
teachings of Buddha, including
the Tantras,
there's nothing that
surpasses these qualities
of caring, love,
and compassion for others.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So it's in
our hands to understand
that anyone thinking that
they're just going to get ahead
by themselves, profit on their
own separate from others,
just does not work in
this world anymore.
We're totally interconnected
like one family
unit with all this mutual love
and compassion for each other.
KHENPO KARTEN
RINPOCHE: How many?
TOM: Five minutes.
KHENPO KARTEN
RINPOCHE: Five minutes.
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So in the work
that you do here-- you know,
I don't know where
to find Google
and where to point to and
say, this is Google here.
Today, it's as if I've come
into contact with Google.
So here you are.
So my kind of advice
is some people
who are involved with
connecting the world
and bringing that
interconnection
awareness-- to try to bring this
attitude of love and compassion
into that to help promote
those kinds of qualities
throughout the world.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So these tools that
connect people in the world,
like Facebook, are very
beneficial to bringing
that connection
and the possibility
of developing love
and compassion.
And as I said
before, in your work
here, to bring to mind
these kinds of things
that he was talking
about of how beings
want happiness, and
don't want suffering,
and everyone is alike in
that, and to bring that kind
of a quality to the work.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN] Example,
OK-- like one example-- I have
my own Facebook [INAUDIBLE].
My Facebook is main use
to be dharma center.
And my center's name is
[INAUDIBLE] Dharma Center.
I always [INAUDIBLE]
some mine teaching
and some other
teachers who teachings
sort of like the Dalai Lama.
Then two years ago, I went to
the monastery in [INAUDIBLE].
The [INAUDIBLE]
say-- I said to them,
because I meet them, so sorry,
so sorry, I never meet you.
You know, it is so long.
Because I are here, and
they really want to see me.
They say, oh, it's OK.
I every day see your Facebook.
Your Facebook is
your dharma center.
That make me very happy.
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So I think
we can think of Google
as an emanation of Buddha.
[LAUGHTER]
Emanations of Buddha
don't necessarily
need to be human beings that
are walking around on two legs.
They can be all
kinds of varieties.
They can be artisans.
It can be-- [SPEAKING TIBETAN].
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: It can
be inanimate objects.
So when Google is used for--
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So he said
that a Buddha could emanate
as a bridge, a huge bridge
that would enable people to get
across the body of water.
So in this way, I
think we can certainly
think of Google as being an
emanation of Buddha when it's
used for these
purposes of developing
harmony and a sense
of interconnectedness
in the world.
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: But how we use
it, it's very important.
We need to be very careful
with how we use such a tool.
TOM: Any last words?
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: I remember
he did say before, too,
that he was very happy
to have this opportunity
to give us a bit of an
induction to the ideas
of Buddhist teachings
in this context.
KHENPO KARTEN RINPOCHE:
[SPEAKING TIBETAN]
DAVID MOLK: So I want to thank
you from the depths of my heart
for this opportunity
to address you here
and the people who've
seen Google for this hour.
As always, when I speak
about the teachings,
I'm not sure how much it will
benefit you to hear them.
Because people have
all different sorts
of ideas and thoughts.
But for me, when I
have the opportunity
to speak on these
subjects and to do it
with a very pure,
altruistic motivation,
then it's so beneficial for me.
So again, I want to thank you
very much for this opportunity.
TOM: Thank you so much
for being here, Rinpoche.
I think I can say on
behalf of all of us
from the bottom of our
hearts how grateful we
are that you have graced
us with your presence
and with your wisdom today.
Thank you for coming.
We hope that you can come
back sometime in the future.
KHENPO KARTEN
RINPOCHE: Thank you.
TOM: And thanks also
to David for all
of your work in translating
and to everyone else
for coming today.
And may we just take 30
seconds and think about all
of our connections in our
work life, in our home life,
and in this world
and think about them,
perhaps benefiting
from these things
that we've learned today--
patience that we may
act locally and think globally.
Thank you.